hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel we're doing another q a this
month where i take
any questions you guys left on last
month's q a and answer them
this video is sponsored by keeps which
means we will hear more from them
somewhere in the middle
instead of letting youtube just
interrupt my video with random ads
in the middle of a sentence so to the
questions uh liam hudson asked hey alana
what are some resources you use to guide
you when making your short film huge fan
and i love your work
thank you i used absolutely no resources
just sean and mark being my
cinematographer and my sound designer
i did not look up anything official
um i just took inspiration from things
that i liked
i spoke about a lot of this stuff in the
director's commentary video that i made
um and i had someone be like hey this is
like
i've seen year one film school students
make this and i was like that's
excellent
as being that i did not go to film
school i take that as a huge compliment
if i'm at their level with no study
whatsoever
we love to see it but no i didn't use
any resources i kind of didn't want to i
wanted to make something that like
you know i knew would not be a general
narrative piece that would not be a
traditional short film that was more
about the creative process for me than
anything else so i didn't want to
be beholden to any rules really
but i'm sure that will change with some
of the more scripted stuff
i intend to make in the future lyndon
campbell said is there a obscure hidden
gem of the game you played in the past
that you would love to see remade
not that much of an obscure hidden gem
um
i guess it is a little like this game is
not unheard of um my answer to this
would be fatal frame
and i say that actually because a friend
recently was like hey i'm looking for
scary games people haven't necessarily
heard of and i recommended fatal frame
to them and they were like yeah i think
it's aged pretty poorly
um which was devastating to me because i
only remember that game from when it
came out and it's awesome
very scary so i feel like an updated
fatal frame
but not an update because i don't want a
new game i would want a remake of
probably fatal frame two that would be
my pick
alex martin said yo i heard godzilla
beats kong is as true does lizard really
beat jack monkey
listen i know it happened like one time
in the 60s
okay but that it garbage throw it in the
trash
if you've ever interacted with like
maybe it's because i'm from australia
where we have these lace monitors
and lizards that like will tear you limb
from limb and then
you take that and you make it huge
and you okay irrelevant even the tiny
lizard
having a nuclear beam that comes from
its mouth
okay what's what's even a regular-sized
gorilla
going to do against a tiny nuclear beam
lizard okay nuclear weapons don't have
to be that big
you just sort of drop them and then an
entire city is destroyed
for a really long time like just for so
long
birth defects a lot of it you're trying
to tell me
that just an upscaled monkey can beat
a walking nuke that also happens to be
part
of a giant reptile with claws
who is angry
it's [ __ ] ridiculous okay it's
absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous
you people are i don't care about the
acts or the tools
it's [ __ ] ridiculous obviously
godzilla wins
come on once again we have like five
questions
in a row about being a video game writer
about the process about what i do
um i'm not talking about any of this
stuff even the vague
questions i'm not answering any of them
part of that
is because i have to be very conscious
of the kind of stuff that i say
when representing a studio where that's
concerned i do not want some shitty
youtuber to watch this video and go oh
sony santa monica does this in this way
let me make a headline about
how i think ragnarok is being made um
because people will do that where video
games are concerned so
i'm not talking about my job at all i'm
sure i will in the future
when people can't try to mine my content
for
hot gossip it's also just really nice
for me i tweeted this
it's as someone who has had a very
public job like a job that
every day people just see in front of
them wow is it nice to have
stuff that's public and then a
completely private professional life
i absolutely love it i'm such a fan russ
barton said how has the reception been
for the short film
largely extremely positive it's been
really nice
yeah also is there any criticism that
might change the way you approach your
next similar project
no i don't think so and the only reason
i say that is because
you know it's not like i think i i know
everything or what i'm doing and that's
definitely like a weird part of being a
public figure is like
you can't just try stuff like people
want you to be perfect at everything
again to the criticism i got where
people like i've seen first grade film
students make better work i'm like yeah
they should they've
got experience and knowledge i don't
have any of that i just
made something but the main thing is
because i'm not trying to make
commercial products i'm not trying to
make things for everyone
i'm just trying to create stuff for fun
it doesn't really concern me um it's
more about the process
about uh doing something creative in my
spare time you know it's not my job it's
not
something i'm trying to make my job i
would
just you know from that perspective i'm
much more interested in just
kind of making the stuff that i want to
make in a way that i find fun and
collaborative with other cool creative
people
rather than making it to be as enjoyable
to as many people as possible i hope
that makes sense you know i did in part
make it because i thought that it would
be very interesting for
for me and for other people who are in
similar situations to me
to look back on or to show to people who
um
went through that kind of sense of
isolation that other people didn't but
if you weren't one of those people it
won't make any sense to you whatsoever
and
my point is just i'm cool with that i
don't i don't need it to appeal to
everyone i'm always gonna learn from the
people that i'm in the room with with
this kind of thing
and i do love learning but yeah i'm not
trying to make something
for people and that's definitely a part
of the way that my brain works
pretty much always that's you know i've
said it a bunch of times before of all
of the stuff that i've written i've
never had any interest in releasing any
of it publicly
because it's the part of making it
appeals to me a lot more than
what other people think of it i know
that's unusual that's just the way my
brain works i don't know
naturally uh you know working at santa
monica studio
probably millions of people will see
something that i am working on
creatively
um obviously ign fun house inside gaming
all of that stuff was public but um i
like having creative projects
that i just do for me that are private
and i am releasing the short films
because they're a visual medium
i feel like it's just very easy to just
post online and just be like
take it if you want but i'm not worried
about appealing to as many people as
possible
or having the broadest audience as
possible or trying to make money or
submitting to film festivals none of
that stuff is currently appealing to me
maybe that'll change over the the course
of creating more stuff but right now
it's just about having fun being
creative um not trying to be a
professional
you know it is time to talk about keeps
did you know that two out of three guys
will experience some form of male
pattern boldness by the time they're 35
and if that's something that you're
insecure about not saying that you
should be
but you know if you are i am in support
of self-care and the best way to prevent
halos is to do something about it while
you still have hair
with keeps you can get treated from home
you used to have to go to the doctor's
office for your hair loss prescription
which could obviously be awkward and
takes effort now thanks to cubes you can
visit a doctor online and get hair loss
medication delivered right
to your home they make it easy and
deliver your medication every three
months so you can say goodbye to
pharmacy checkout lines and awkward
doctor visits
though still love that you do have to
see a medical professional for this kind
of thing
we're a big fan of that keeps also
offers generic versions of the only two
fda approved hair loss products out
there
find out why keeps has more five star
reviews than any of its competitors and
why hundreds and thousands of men
trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention medication i actually asked a
couple of people who use keeps before
agreeing
to take them as a sponsor and they all
had really lovely things to say
so if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
alana pierce or click the link in the
description to receive 50
off your first order that is k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash alana pierce back to the
video ark sector asked what is the
biggest difference you've noticed about
american citizens political atmosphere
and engagement versus australian
citizens i suspect that things have
changed since i left australia which is
six years ago now
but i will say america generally feels
more partisan to me
um at least it did to again the
australia that i lived in
six years ago when i was 21. you know
political discourse
in america and it is generally online i
don't know that i'm speaking about this
in terms of the real world i think
people do often forget that twitter is
not real life way too often but i will
say something
and then someone will assign a motive to
me or words to me that i never said just
based on them assuming a political party
so there's not a lot of area for for
grey in any kind of conversations i feel
like a lot of the time we just aren't as
aggressively like this party versus this
party
again i suspect it might have changed
because i think a lot of the online
discourse has kind of
shifted a lot of this stuff and uh
definitely contributed to globalization
where
a lot of countries even politically you
know with their different political
parties
um are potentially becoming more
americanized just by virtue of how many
americans are
driving the conversation on these kinds
of apps so i don't know but that is the
thing that always stood out to me yeah
america's very bipartisan
there are two parties you belong to a
party you must belong to that party
exactly
uh i will assign uh things or opinions
or stances to you based on the fact that
you belong in that party and it goes
both ways 100
like people who are democrats are doing
that to republicans republicans are
doing that to democrats
across the board okay so i just debated
if i'm even going to answer this
question but i have gotten it a few
times recently with like
oddly increasing hostility and have
addressed it on a couple of streams
so we're going to do it and then i'm
going to remove this comment
because this person is brutal um this is
from underscore the
underscore mcbreyer9 and says why are
you keeping your relationship a secret i
find it very hypocritical
and gross and then they go on to call me
a bunch of names
um so like i said this is something i
don't even really want to address uh
truthfully it is
nobody else's business but i will say
because i've said it before just to
address it
for you know the increasing amount that
people are asking me about this
it's not my choice there are two people
in a relationship i don't care who knows
what essentially people are assigning a
lot of like motive to this thing that
there is no
no motive from me about whatsoever
essentially but like i said
relationships with two people that's it
joey seamus asks how do you balance a
full-time game dev with content creation
and streaming
it's very simple i finish my job
and then i do the other stuff i get
asked about this all the time but it
really is that simple
you know my workout is a nine to six and
then i usually give myself like an hour
break
and then i do other stuff so it's just
obviously the balance would always be in
favor of my job right so like
if my job is busier in any given week or
i'm super tired from like a super busy
work day
then i won't make a video i won't do
content creation i won't stream but
yeah it's not difficult to separate
those two things as like it's
essentially two jobs
one of them gets the chunk of the day
like the vast majority of the day and
the other one gets the nighttime
um yeah it's it's not hard it's you know
i wouldn't recommend it for most people
i like
working a lot a lot of people don't but
separating it in that way is like is
just so simple adam litzinger asked hey
elena what's the first thing you're
planning on doing
after being fully vaccinated i'm so
close
it'll be in a month i'm so close get a
tattoo
go see a movie that's it also i'd really
love to get my nails done
get a haircut it's it's so much hair
it's just you know it's so long
it's just go
and see a film also i really want
like a fresh beer or cider thinking
about that
all the time atreyu said hey elena i'm a
huge fan and you're an amazing human
being who always inspires me thank you
now i have a weird cue but here we go
what is the best way to be friends with
you
i'd love to have someone like you in my
life and being friends would be so dope
i understand if you don't answer this
but hopefully one day i can have an
opportunity to be a friend
this is a very harmless comment written
very politely
um but the truth is there isn't a way
and i don't think you should try i'm
trying to say this in the most helpful
way possible
in terms of like how these kinds of
relationships work where like you see a
content creator and you think you want
to be their friend
um the truth is that you ultimately
don't know me that well
and to like look at someone and be like
i'm gonna be friends with that person um
just based on knowing them on the
internet i think it's probably even
setting you up to fail it's probably not
gonna head
in um an organic direction you might be
awkward or dishonest in your
interactions because you have this goal
of being
friends with someone where i think uh a
i'm a person who doesn't make a lot of
friends anyway i'm extremely guarded and
that's my bad and something that i need
to figure out how to fix
but especially guarded with people who
know me from the internet um
it's something that can be very
uncomfortable just for like privacy
reasons
you know it just i think can in a lot of
ways be
um an unhealthy expectation to set for
yourself or for the person that you
think that you want to be friends with
so yeah again nothing wrong with this
comment you've not said anything that i
think is wrong and i don't want to make
you feel bad in any way but i also want
to say i think that this is something
that you should never try to focus on
with the people that you see on the
internet i think that those two things
should
in a lot of cases stay separate
especially if it's something that you
are actively trying to do i feel like
that's setting up
um a lot of potential harm and for me to
answer like what is the best way to be
friends with me and give you a list
would be effectively me telling you how
to like manipulate me
into having uh even a platonic
relationship with you which seems like a
bad idea
for both parties but i appreciate you
asking this is very polite thank you
um just something that i think is worth
considering is like just try to drop
that
from from your mind if you can at all
that the people that you watch online
are just entertainers behind a screen
and not people that you should be
putting any real effort into uh
developing
actual relationships with because i
think a lot of negative stuff and
a lot of expectations uh can come from
there pagan plays
asked uh was it harder to deal with
trolls or negative comments about you
and your content when you were just
starting out as opposed to now in
essence does being in the public eye
longer desensitize
you to the point when it comes to those
negative comments i actually hadn't
thought about this
um and also thank you for the kind words
you also wrote in here
um but yes i think it did bother me more
when i was starting out because like
when you're just starting out
you're like why are all these people
attacking me what the [ __ ] like what did
i do
like i didn't ask for any of this like i
didn't ask for these people to follow me
like what what is
what is happening whereas now it just
like is part of it
that doesn't bother me really at all i
will sometimes engage with a negative
comment or a troll because i
enjoy it and that's the thing i keep
having to tell people who are like why
do you even reply
i just sometimes really like it it's a
nice outlet when you get a lot of
negative stuff thrown at you if you just
reply to
one in every 10 it's a nice release i
think
makes it feel less like you're just
dealing with this wave of garbage
and not being allowed to fight back i
get way more annoyed at people
who tell me to ignore the trolls than i
get at the trolls like the trolls don't
annoy me at all
but the people who are like why do you
even reply though i'm like [ __ ] off but
yeah no i do think that
i am extremely desensitized um there's
stuff that i've tweeted about
as jokes like comments that people have
made that i just tweet about as a joke
and then people are like oh my god are
you do you need to go to police and i'm
like
no what this is super normal um
and sometimes it catches me off guard
just how desensitized i am
to a lot of behavior that i don't care
about at all
when it comes to stuff like deep fakes i
have people warn me all the time be like
there's this video of you that somebody
made they put your face on a porn star
and you need to know about this you need
to have it removed i'm like they're just
gonna keep making it like this
it's it's whatever there's nothing i can
do about it um sometimes people think
those videos are real and email me and
like this leaked viewer and you really
need to know
even pictures that are just photoshopped
it's stuff that i have to be like it's
fine whereas to other people
even coming to me it seems like
extremely scary
and i have been doing this for a lot
longer than i planned so ah we'll leave
it at this one shall we
love this question well i just love to
be asked this after
all i've done devon
barcelona said would you ever start on
only fans for like cosplays or non-nude
content
naturally i have answered this before
and the answer is no
it's not because i have any issue with
people doing only fans i have a lot of
friends who do it i'm hugely in support
of it i think it's cool if that's a
thing that they want to do
i like seeing pretty women and men
taking cool pictures of themselves
looking hot
i uh have a lot of creative outlets um
and would much prefer to dedicate my
time to doing the stuff i do like
writing
like playing video games like making
short films like
uh making youtube videos literally
anything else that does not involve me
taking a picture of myself
uh because it is something i have never
enjoyed i do not
enjoy being photographed under any
circumstances um i don't care if it's
like for cosplays or non-nude content
but me like posing in front of a camera
is just not something
i find creatively fulfilling or
inspiring or fun
even remotely so yeah it's not a stigma
against that kind of content or the
people who create that kind of content i
just wouldn't enjoy it i'm gonna go make
another short film
instead i think um and that is it for me
today everyone
thank you so much to everyone who asked
questions thank you to keeps for
sponsoring this video i will leave a
link
in the description below to where you
can find out more about them and
i will see you guys next time bye